how much do you spend yearly on medical
school gosh do I have a boyfriend so
hard
good morning here I am with
and James I am a second year medical
student I'm a fourth year and I'm a
fourth year medical student as well
first question that we're going to start
with how much do you spend yearly on
medical school right
as an intuition fee yeah 9 250 pounds
psycho student if you're at home UK
students must be nice International
students price starts around 27 to 29
000 and it goes up each year so I think
this year is about 30 000. yeah yeah so
that's the difference between
International and home what camera do I
use it's Sony z31f let's move on to the
next which editing app do I use it's
Final Cut Pro of course how did you take
your decision to become a medical
student what's your motivation well for
me I always liked science is this a
classic answer I would like science and
but I didn't want to be a researcher I
wanted to be more around people and be
like the first Contact for patients what
about you so I think mine's probably
even more cliche I always wanted to do
medicine since you were younger back
when I was a kid I used to sort of take
the stuffing out of dolls grasshoppers
apart and should I
[Applause]
just be honest since I was a little nope
how do you get the confidence to go
through medical school once you do the
work and once you know that you've done
your best then you become more confident
and sometimes you're just gonna fake it
fake the confidence most medical
students question themselves I think
they're not enough it happens to me it
happens to me yeah
just roll with it do your best take it
till you make it is definitely the way
to go also Practice Medical School is
the place to make the mistakes just go
to the patients take history as much as
you can learn what you can from the
doctors and from the patients themselves
over time you'll just see yourself
becoming more and more like a doctor do
you have any siblings do you guys know
whether I have innocent things or not I
think you do how many
[Music]
oh it's three sisters I've got
three sisters I'm so grateful for them
they're my best friends very
sweet
[Music]
depends last time I measured it was
three days ago I measured it in the
hospital and you were 172.5 centimeters
almost five foot eight the next question
was do I have a boyfriend do you
I don't have a boyfriend but honestly
even if I had one the last thing I would
do would be to post about it online
because I have a traditional Turkish dad
honestly serious I would not go into a
relationship
hope that makes sense anyway was getting
into Medical School easy no I don't
think any of us had an easy
thing no some of you might know I also
transferred to a medical Sciences to
Medicine along with James we were both
amongst that top eight people the very
top oh weren't near the top in the
clubhouse
yeah I took a longer route so I
completed medical Sciences I finished my
degree right after that in my final year
I applied to do medicine what field of
medicine do you want to specialize in
the future to me it's Dermatology
hopefully I'm still keeping my options
open do I know BTS yes I do know BTS
everyone knows in this world's Korean
boy band and they have a really cool
songs and my sisters are obsessed for
example they're more of a Japanese
listener myself I've heard of them yeah
I don't listen to them don't
underestimate BTS army people just stay
neutral yeah
how do you deal with major mental
breakdown during medical school what do
you do when you feel low and home set
yeah that's a heavy question I'd like to
take it slow and treat myself better and
just talk it out my family is there like
great support I call my mom let myself
literally be in bed for the whole day
and do nothing and the next day you can
recover sometimes you're just gonna stop
make a breather and have a good cry yeah
I never cry guys that's a lie you can
always talk and we'll put that song up
on her Spotify yeah
do you ever regret going to medical
school I'm a first year and I'm having
lots of doubts I've never I have last
year when I was sort of really
struggling to think oh do I want to stay
in med school are there other things I'm
sort of passionate about and you always
have these thoughts you're not alone in
thinking that but I think it's a matter
of trying to think about the positives
as well putting yourself out there
getting involved and I can push through
this degree when I finish the degree I
can sort of think about other things
another thing I really had a proper
feeling of regret to going to medical
school because before medical school I
did try to get work experience from
Pharmacy researcher I did try all of
them there's times where it's extremely
difficult and you just ask yourself why
am I doing this but in those times you
look back on the reason that started all
of this what's my stethoscope color
Brown mine's pink mine is blue that's
okay
this will be present to people
when will you marry Ramadan routine how
do you stay so disciplined well you
can't always stay so discipline and I
don't think I'm always so disciplined
even though you always want to be
motivated and be efficient but when
you're not motivated to still get your
work done motivation is kind of
overrated just get it done you'll feel
so much better about yourself just do it
how do you stay so difficult you don't
everyone has phases where they just
don't want to do work and you just have
to accept that and plan around it like
you're gonna have a social life you're
going to have events You're Gonna Want
to celebrate your birthday
that's specifically
yeah trigger the next question is what
motivates you my Visa I want to be the
best doctor I can be for my patients
that's like the Deep answer more
practical realistic answers when you
have deadlines when you have exams
coming up you know that you don't want
to be struggling what motivates me is
you have that inner Drive in you that
you want to do your best I want to enjoy
mine now and I want my future itself to
enjoy her life as well and be a happy
person so that's why I'd like to do my
best are you an introvert or an
extrovert what do you guys think
introverts I think you're an ambita
whenever I do those personality
questions I always come up as like 70
extrovert but I think it really depends
whether I feel comfortable around Jonah
and whether I want to hang out with you
or not which is the case with most
people I would say yeah are you dating a
ghost we love to see it oh wow gosh
what's my favorite animal or a pet cats
I love cats I have a cat I love dogs I
have a dog or two differently dogs
what's your favorite Netflix show I
don't know my favorite one but the last
show that I watched on Netflix was you
where do you study medicine before we
continue with the rest of the video I
want to present you Squarespace it's a
publishing platform to create a website
or a Blog this is the blog I created
about medical students one of my
favorite features that you can highlight
important text to emphasize your point
and it's formed in drag and drop blocks
so you can move stuff freely around and
design it however you want for example I
dragged and dropped this bright red
arrow to point out neuer's natural
candid smile or if you're feeling lazy
you can just choose a design from one of
the beautiful ready-made templates so if
you're interested in creating your own
site go to squarespace.com for a free
trial and when you're ready to launch go
to squarespace.com to save 10 of your
first purchase of a website or a domain
I study at Exeter medical school in the
UK we all three of us do what's my
favorite color neutral colors like
creamy I like pink sorry my favorite
color is pink specifically baby pink not
that anyone cares I care my girl thanks
how to budget at Uni
don't eat out and cook eating out waste
so so much money if you had to choose a
different job in your life what would it
be I'd be a Pianist law or politics can
I change mine I didn't read pianist I'm
a music teacher I want to study business
create my own business where are you
living
I live in history all my family members
are also doctors my older sister is a
doctor here in the UK but other than
that in my close family
I think I need to leave breathe quiet
yeah yeah actually and my younger sister
is applied to medicine you're an
aquarius no question that's an
assumption um I'm not an aquarius I am
Scorpius Sagittarius because I was born
on 22nd of November so does that mean
what excites me the most Dermatology
how difficult uh sorry how difficult was
it initially to grow your social media
platform wait when did I start James is
my old flatmate so he was there with me
was it like May last year it did take me
three or four months to hit 100K it was
a very slow at first then when we do
blew up and then are you planning to be
a doctor or a YouTuber in the future I
want to be able to balance both of them
hopefully I never called myself a
YouTuber it feels weird what's your
favorite movie Leon the Professional
it's really good Spider-Man to the OG oh
yeah did you ever cry during your school
journey I probably cried yesterday about
my med school Journey
yes I have I have not this guy never
cries
all the time do you mind adopting me of
course come here
we've got you what's your favorite way
to relax being home back home in my
family home and being in my bed doing
nothing eating good food you know that
some of your followers have nothing to
do with medicine studies I.E me yes some
of my followers are not involved in
medicine at all still here to support me
I appreciate every one of you and I'm so
grateful for every one of you did you
ever feel pressured by your parents into
going to med school no I haven't my
sister is already a doctor so my dad was
like maybe you should think about
something different yeah I'd say the
same as probably the opposite as well
how long does it take you to edit a
video it must be hard for you especially
when you're busy honestly it's super
super hard and it's super time consuming
it sometimes takes a full five days of
editing so 12 times five 60 hours I'm
hoping to be able to afford to hire an
editor where you restrict a student
since high school definitely in primary
school I was actually more towards the
bottom of the class when I was in year
four in primary school my teacher sent
me to psychiatrist because they thought
I had a learning disability I was like
always like pretty high yeah I'm one of
the top oh okay I peaked in gcses sort
of downhill from there if you could
travel to any country which one would it
be Indonesia Japan South Korea and
Nigeria of course Nigeria yeah the
number one priority is going to visit
Japan what's your skincare I did make a
video about it and you can watch it
is it gonna be on this year did I dye my
hair or or think or is it natural it's
not real it's typed wow they're just
like the ends right it's not like that
different from your natural hair we want
to know if your family lives in the UK
too yes I do hope you
hope you bye guys
I don't know how you're gonna make that
into a nice video good luck thanks
they're actually good footage I don't
know we'll see